recycling advice and help
good news rochford district council is
pleased to announce that you can now
recycle all food and drink cartons and
all envelopes with and without windows
in your grey recyclables bin the council
has started working with upm who will
sort out all the recyclable material
from the kerbside recyclables
collections
there's a new contract and there are a
few things we'd like to ask you to do to
help make sure it runs smoothly
where possible squash all plastic
bottles and put the lid back on
all lids should be placed back on glass
bottles and jars plastic bottles and
food and drinks cartons
beware your bin may not get emptied if
you have the wrong items in your
recyclables or compostables bin
if you have any black sacs in the
recyclables or compostable spin these
types of bags can only be used in the
non-recyclable bin
or if you have any plastic bags in your
compostables bin the only bags you can
use in this bin are 100 compostable bags
with the seedling logo on them
you can also wrap your food waste in
newspaper or place it in the bin loose
you can place any larger pieces of
cardboard folded down next to your
recyclables bin on the day of your
recycling collection
and don't forget batteries
around 600 million household batteries
are sent to landfill unnecessarily every
year in the uk according to figures from
waste and resources
action program
you can recycle household batteries at
all the libraries council reception
areas in rochford and rayleigh and also
in most schools around the district so
please keep an eye out for the boxes
rodford district council in partnership
with the waste contractor ceta uk
provides a chargeable collection service
of large bulky household furniture and
electrical household items
the charges for the collection of bulky
waste household furniture and electrical
household items are as follows
up to three items 15 pounds and then
it's five pounds per additional item for
items booked at the same time and please
note all items must be booked at the
same time
the furniture collected under the bulky
waste scheme will be taken to landfill
so please think about whether the items
can be reused before you book a
collection
if they're in good condition then you
may wish to consider contacting a
charity shop some of whom may be able to
collect
please check with your local charity
shops before you take any items there to
find your nearest charity shop please
visit the website
www.rochford.gov
dot uk
forward slash recycling
alternatively there are a number of
organizations which reuse your old or
unwanted items these can also be found
in the related links on the website
if you're unable to reuse your item and
wish to arrange collection and payment
please call the customer services on
zero one seven zero two three one eight
one double one during the hours of 8 30
a.m to 5 pm monday to thursday
and 8 30 to 4 30 on fridays
additionally payment can be made by
check payable to rochefort district
council and buy cash at the council
offices in south street rochford and the
civic suite hockley road railing
please note that after a payment has
been made there are no refunds if you
choose to cancel
on the website is a list of the items we
do and do not take however this is not
exhaustive
if there are any items not listed on the
website and you require collection
please call us
you can also email us on customer
services
at rochford.gov dot uk to check if we
could collect the items for you
looking after our local landmarks from
fountains in hockley to post boxes in
ashland rochefort district council want
to know which historic land local
landmarks are important to you
the council is currently seeking your
views as to which buildings you consider
to be local heritage assets or
lhas across the district there are
numerous buildings and items of street
furniture called local heritage assets
which are locally important and
contribute to the character of the area
but are not considered to merit listed
building status following national
guidance and the recognized importance
of retaining and enhancing local built
heritage the council is in the process
of developing a list of those local
heritage assets called the local list
through this list the council will seek
to protect important local heritage
assets by working with owners and other
interested parties
rochford district council's portfolio
holder for planning and transportation
councillor keith hudson said over the
past few years we have lost some
architectural treasures perhaps not
worthy of listed building status but
nevertheless important to the residents
of rochford district
the restoration of the local list will
go some way in affording protection to
our heritage for the benefit of
generations to come
the council has prepared a document for
you to view and have your say which
includes local heritage assets that had
previously been identified in the 1990s
in conjunction with essex county council
and additional suggestions from parish
and town councils
not all of those included in the
consultation document may warrant
inclusion on the local list
the buildings and items of street
furniture in the consultation document
have been assessed against a set of
criteria developed from national
guidance
an important part of the consultation is
to receive views and opinions of the
assessment and additional information
about the history of each entry
the local list consultation document is
available for public viewing and comment
until 6th of may 2011 and may also be
submitted via our online consultation
system at rochford.jd
hyphen consult dot net
forward slash ldf
if you do not have access to the
internet or would like further
information contact the planning policy
team on zero one seven zero two three
one eight one nine one or planning dot
policy at rochefort dot gov dot uk
if you currently hold a bus pass issued
by rochford district council which
expired on the 31st of march
there is no need to complete the contact
the council or complete a renewal
application form
your bus pass should have been
automatically renewed and sent to you
toward the end of march
the design of the new passes has changed
slightly as essex county council is now
responsible for the management of bus
passes within essex although rochford
district council will continue to issue
the passes on behalf of the county
council
there will be no changes to the current
use of the bus pass which will continue
to be between 9 00 am and midnight
monday to friday
and at any time during weekends and
public holidays within essex only
however in all other counties in england
you can use your bus pass from 9 30 a.m
to 11 p.m monday to friday and at any
time during weekends and public holidays
the new bus passes will expire on the
30th of november
2015
for those with surnames beginning from a
to l
for those with surnames beginning with m
to zed the past will expire on the 31st
of march 2016.
and here's some frequently asked
questions with the answers
i've changed my address within the
district since my last bus pass was
issued do i need to notify you
yes
if you have moved and have not already
notified
the council's transportation department
of a change of address your bus pass may
have been sent to your old address
please contact transportation for advice
on zero one two six eight
seven nine eight six zero eight
i now live in the rockford district but
i have a bus pass issued by the previous
authority where i lived
do i need to apply to rochefort for a
new bus pass
if your previous address was in south
end thorac or anywhere else in the
country then yes
you must contact rochford district
council and complete a bus pass
application form you must also contact
your previous authority to advise them
to cancel your bus paths
however
if you lived anywhere else within essex
there is no need for your bus pass to be
replaced as rochwood district council
issued the passes to all residents on
behalf of essex county council
you must however contact rochwood
district council to advise them of your
change of address for their records
my partner relative or close friend has
recently passed away
should i contact the council and return
their bus pass for cancellation
yes
you should contact the council and
return the bus pass as soon as possible
for cancellation
i am no longer able to use my bus pass
should i inform the council that i do
not require a renewal
yes
you should contact the council and
return your bus pass as soon as possible
after cancellation
can i use my current bus pass after the
31st of march 2011
no
however should there be any delays in
dispatching the new bus passes for any
reason essex county council will
publicize information accordingly
if you have any more questions about the
concessionary bus pass scheme please
email transportation at rochford.gov dot
uk
or phone
zero one two six eight
seven
nine eight six zero eight
residents and visitors in north rochford
will now benefit from the introduction
of a new shopper bus service which
started in february
the service route number 174 crouch
village link operates every tuesday and
saturday
leaving from canudan at 9 43 am and 1 47
pm and traveling via south fanbridge the
dome caravan park ashington medical
center and rochford railway station to
tesco south end hospital and south end
central railway station
the return journeys from south end
central railway station leave at 11 50
a.m and 4 p.m
this service has timed stops in the
villages but can be adapted to meet the
needs of the passenger
as long as it's safe to do so the bus
will stop along the route within the
village when hailed
between the 1st of march and the 31st of
october the service will follow the same
route but will start earlier leaving
rochford railway station at 9 00 am
this will include an additional stop at
wallacey island providing access to the
burnham ferry at essex marina which
operates on saturdays
riverside village caravan park and the
wallacy rspb site the return journey
from wallacey island will leave at 104
pm and 5 14 pm
the cost of the journey will be 2 pounds
flat fare single return
children aged 5 to 16 travel half price
and children under 5 travel free if you
hold a concessionary bus pass you will
need to show your pass to receive free
transport
and for any further information please
call zero one seven zero two
five double four double five one or
zero one seven zero two
five four three zero one zero
the tax voucher scheme has ended due to
the reduction in government funding and
budget cuts regressively the council is
no longer in a position to continue to
offer the taxi voucher travel concession
to its residents and the scheme ended on
march 31st
the taxi voucher scheme was introduced
in the district in 2002 to assist those
residents with severe restrictive
mobility
to access essential services at that
time there was no other means of
supporting those residents with their
travel needs
rochford district council was the only
authority in essex to offer this
additional travel subsidy to its
residents however in the last nine years
since the scheme was introduced other
subsidised transport services have now
become available
it was a very difficult decision for the
council to decide to withdraw this
scheme and it is appreciated that users
will now have to make alternative travel
arrangements
taxi drivers will continue to offer the
same level of service to all their
customers however with the ending of the
voucher scheme journeys will no longer
be subsidised by the council
wyvern community transport wct
run services within the district and
offer an excellent door-to-door service
for residents with restrictive mobility
taxi voucher scheme users can find out
more about wct's services by calling
zero one seven zero two
five double four double five one between
nine thirty am and one pm monday to
friday information is also available on
the council's website at
www.rochford.gov dot uk or telephone the
council's transportation department on
zero one two six eight
seven nine 798608